little jugnu is it true that keeping
urine and bladder for a longer time than
usual risks kidney health oh this is
really good I haven't done a responding
to comments video in quite a long time
with culvert 19 and my recent addiction
to these gaming videos I think it's time
Ethan green I haven't had remembered a
dream for more than eight years now
absolutely no recall or memory of any
dream is this a problem or doesn't
matter it doesn't matter not everyone
remembers their dreams in fact some
people that even remember their dreams
it doesn't happen to them every night
it's like a natural variance amongst
humans Zachary Kornfeld question the
seltzer water and normal water give you
the same hydration yes I think they give
you the same amount of hydration I do
think that seltzer water is not great
for those who are suffering with reflux
meaning like acid reflux because it
could cause you to burp it can also
cause the sphincter up here to not work
well the sphincter is actually what
keeps the acid in the stomach that's
where you want the acid to be because
when it starts coming up and refluxing
back into the esophagus actually starts
creating irritation that's when you get
the feeling of Harper make sure that
you're only drinking seltzer if you're
not suffering with that type of
heartburn and not too close to bedtime
do you still consult a doctor when
you're sick or you consult yourself our
Mon great question I consult myself as
well as the resources that I use for my
patients like if a patient comes in with
a rare condition that I'm not a hundred
percent sure how to treat I do consult
those same sources whether they're
websites
textbooks however sometimes I do go
reach out for help
questions so as long as I can remember
my ankle has been cracking and that's
every time I'm or it I think you mean
you move it but check this out
I don't know if you hear it my ankles
crack back when I walk up the steps
my friends judge me they're like dude
why do you sound like you're 95 years
old I'm like yeah play me a ball one on
one and we'll see how many years old I
am
[Music]
banks open on Tuesdays folks why do I
feel a little heartbeat on the places I
hurt like the tip of my fingers you mean
like the the pulsating feeling that you
feel in your fingers like when you hit
them or Jam them the pulsating feeling
is a lot of blood rushing to that area
to clot to bring healing factors
inflammatory cells it also gets warmer
it gets redder those are all signs of
inflammation it's how your body knows
something's going on
cuddle muffins does your heart stop when
you sneeze sometimes when I sneeze
multiple times my chest starts to hurt
well first of all your heart stopped
beating all the time it beats relaxes
beats relaxes so if you happen to sneeze
at the time it relaxes your heart's not
beating that I don't know if that counts
the reason you're probably experiencing
chest pain when you sneeze multiple
times rapidly is because when you're
trying to sneeze your body's also trying
to breathe and inhale your loss like
expand your lungs and when you try and
expand your chest those muscles are
being pulled out but at the same time
you're sneezing so it almost becomes
like a pulled muscle in between your
ribs imagine doing a curl and then all
of a sudden something comes and stops
you from doing it it strains the muscle
and pulls it you know that was in the
greatest demonstration but I tried
Hannibal on my resting BPM has gone up
to 160 I'm still young but I don't think
this is usual is there a problem and
should I go to the doctor absolutely you
should go as soon as like you can the
reason why I'm saying this is the
resting heart rate should be 60 to 100
beats per minute anytime when you're at
rest and it's going above a hundred
there needs to be a physiological reason
why that's happening either a you're
consuming a substance that's raising
your heart rate caffeine drugs standing
up and you're going to exercise heavily
that should that can raise your your
heart rate stress anxiety can raise it
but tu-160 that's a very high heart rate
that signals to me that something
abnormal is going on that desperately
needs to be checked now Julian vlogs is
having interaction with your pet such as
being licked hugged kissed hugging them
or kissing them is hard
I was an aggressive very slow motion
kiss it's probably not great advice for
doctors to say that your dog should lick
you because there is bacteria in his
mouth
probably not beneficial in the long long
term and there is a potential risk but
like when I cuddle with him and he
kisses me oxytocin gets released and
that's like a cuddle hormone it makes
you feel good it lowers your stress
hormone levels so I love it
but medically I can't recommend this
type of licking
are you done John Paul Turing again how
can I remove white stretch marks on my
shoulders stretch marks are really
difficult if not impossible to remove
good way to think about them as almost
like scar tissue
it's literally from your skin being
overly stretched and scar tissue being
laid down there are a few what we call
like aesthetic or plastic surgery esque
procedures that can cut out these
stretch marks but those come with
obvious risks and you need to weigh the
pros and cons for you the creams that
are out there maybe they can help with
the softness or the suppleness of your
skin but it's not gonna make the stretch
marks completely disappear
surgical procedures possibly some laser
procedures and then creams
that's the order of efficacy going from
best to worst how come when I wash my
hands and then dry them they're still
wet and no need to say my name did you
dry them well like are you using a heavy
moisturizer are you sweating if you're
sweating
are you nervous what are you nervous
about we nervous I was gonna try and
pronounce your name your hand shouldn't
be wet after you dry them
Karen Andrews hi dr. Mike love your
content my question is whenever you
cough up any phlegm is it better to spit
it out or just swallow it or does it
matter it doesn't really matter
me personally like if it's large enough
I spit it out because it's uncomfortable
but if it's like a small amount feel
free to swallow it you're like your
body's capable of disinfecting it
because your gastric contents have such
a low pH meaning it's such an acidic
environment kills any bacteria that will
be problematic a naturopath told me once
that drinking while eating discourages
the enzymes to work what would you say
to that please I love drinking while
eating water it kind of fills up my
stomach and it prevents me from
overeating and it helps food travel down
my esophagus and imagine we could just
make our digestive enzymes not work
because we had some water oh my god we
would be the least effective organism on
the planet humans have survived
thousands of years but if water goes
into our system the same time we have a
big back we can't get its nutrients I
went a little heavy on that sorry
naturopath friends of mine little jug No
is it true that keeping urine and
bladder for a longer time than usual
risks kidney health so let's start with
explaining that the average human
bladder holds 16 ounces of urine which
is two couples two couples of here
literally so these are eight ounces each
letting your brain know when it's time
to go is a really complex process so if
you continuously strain your bladder you
could actually cause yourself some
serious problems you may retain urine
after you urinate you don't have control
over your urination you could
potentially have an increase in urinary
tract infections this isn't necessarily
proven logically it makes sense that if
you're keeping day you're in stagnant
that bacteria has a higher chance to
multiply in that area but look if you're
just holding it for a few minutes
hour - it's not a big deal know that
your initial urge to go urinate usually
happens when your bladders about half
full that's a good time for you to go
and urinate but if you need to wait an
hour - your body can handle it is
Saturday truly for the boys no Saturday
is for bear he's a boy you're right it
is for the boys Nico why does my anxiety
cause anxiety why am i more anxious in
the evenings well it's because anxiety
is a vicious vicious
and in fact one of the steps that we try
and teach our patients to do it's not to
not have anxiety because that's a very
difficult thing but it's to control the
thoughts you have about anxiety so if
your thoughts are driving your anxiety
to become worse and we address those
thoughts you could potentially cut down
your anxiety about your anxiety it's
with CBT is cognitive behavioral therapy
check it out
highly recommended not just for those
who suffer with anxiety but everyone on
the planet
I just CBT on myself quite often my
question if someone wakes up in the
middle of surgery what do you do I
encourage them to go back to sleep with
some medicine
Theo filos missed questioned a sudden
pain breaking your wrist increase the
chances of passing out absolutely
passing out from extreme anxiety stress
pain even seeing your own blood all of
this is a survival mechanism to not
overwhelm you you could absolutely pass
out from sudden pain in fact one of the
hallmark signs of breaking a bone could
be passing out and getting really
nauseous at the same time well not at
the same time because if you passed out
you're not nauseous but those are two
signals like I remember once I've only
broken one bone in my body my left wrist
I was snowboarding I thought I was
really cool and I wasn't on the bunny
slope and I fell and right away I got so
nauseous it wasn't even painful but that
nausea I knew I knew there was something
wrong and when I came home my dad told
me yep you broke your scaphoid just a
bone in the wrist one of the most
commonly broken bones in the human body
I like to sing sometimes me too
not very good at it my question is is it
possible for someone who is partially
disabled I have pots to go into med
school I want to become a pathologist
that is it something that has played a
huge part in my life
anaemia and it has always been
interesting to me I think that you
should absolutely follow your dreams
just make sure that you're aware of what
you can do and can't do so that you
don't put yourself in a dangerous
position or your patient in a dangerous
position so for example if you know that
you cannot stand for an extended period
of time don't do that just to please
someone else explain what you're limited
in and find alternatives or find
programs who all for alternatives in
order for you to participate in that
education
no person should be withheld in
education simply because they have a
disability Maria who question for dr.
Mike how does the lack of affection
affect your health see what you did
there Maria social connections late into
your life play a huge role in the
quality of your life and the length of
your life these have to be meaningful
social connections they have to be
positive ones like is it beneficial to
your health to get married it depends if
you have a happy marriage happy marriage
yes very sad abusive marriage no if your
getting positive affection from your dog
from your partner absolutely that's good
for your health it lowers your stress
hormone you get a release of oxytocin
which is that cuddling hormone makes you
feel good about yourself motivates you
lowers your blood pressure
in fact affection encourages you to do
things like go outside for a walk
experience new things and all of those
things are good for the human mind and
body my body do you know the truth about
cracking your knuckles or the truth
about swallowing your gum maybe what
they told you isn't true click on one of
these and find out
oh yeah and stay happy and healthy
[Music]